und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und christian sievers
guten abend hinein die bundesrepublik
deutschland leistet sich 16 verschiedene
schulsysteme jedem bundesland sein
eigenes dass bildung bei uns ländersache
ist verteidigen die mit aller macht
schöner land deshalb ist es ein
hingucker wenn heute die
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
der bundesländer zusammensitzen um eine
einheitliche regeln zu finden was
passieren soll wenn ein kind in der
schule corona hat welche quarantäne dann
gelten sollen und für wen denn was da
derzeit geschieht in deutschland geht
nicht nur je nach bundesland wild
durcheinander sondern häufig sogar nach
der jeweiligen stadt zu verstehen und
gar zu vermitteln ist das kaum noch wie
benjamin chudnofsky berichtet
8 uhr heute morgen erster schultag am
evangelischen gymnasium im thüringischen
meiningen zwei wochen wird hier nun
getestet und maske getragen so viel
steht fest kompliziert wird es beim
ersten positivtests
[Musik]
davon ausgehen dass es einen positiven
fall gibt zum beispiel in einer klasse
also in der a klasse die es bei uns gibt
dann müssen wir natürlich zwei tage
zurück verfolgen in welchen kursen hat
er drin gesessen oder diejenige und dann
würden wir die entsprechenden
fremdsprachen schüler oder die
entsprechenden wahlpflicht schüler die
eben dazu gehören auch noch mit dem
quarantine versetzen sollte es aber dann
am ende nicht die komplette klassenstufe
betrifft sondern nur die a klasse und
einem teil der b klasse das passt zur
komplexen lage im land 16 länder 16
regelungen beispiele im saarland gilt
zwei tests pro woche und masken pflicht
bei positiv-test quarantäne für die
ganze klasse rheinland pfalz zwei tests
pro woche nicht für genesen oder
geimpfte niedersachsen tägliche
testpflicht quarantäne für die ganze
lerngruppe sachsen-anhalt verpflichtende
schnelltests ab dem ersten schultag
bremen zwei tests pro woche keine masken
dafür die ganze klasse in quarantäne den
rest ersparen wir ihn
gesundheitsminister sparen sprach sich
am mittag für einheitlichkeit und eine
verkürzung der quarantäne aus 14 tage
ist natürlich eine lange zeit
insbesondere wenn es um kita und schule
geht was ja auch dann für die eltern
sehr sehr herausfordernd ist
gerade für familien scheint die
unklarheit der regeln bisher wohl
besonders belastend
eltern müssen wissen ob sie ihre kinder
in die einrichtung schicken können ob
sie arbeiten gehen können das sind ja
ganz wichtige fragestellungen die alle
berühren und die ewigen diskussionen die
wir jetzt haben
verunsichern die menschen am frühen
abend dann der offizielle beschluss der
gesundheitsminister schüler innen ohne
symptome die enge kontaktpersonen eines
oder einer positiv getesteten waren
können sich nach fünf tagen aus der
quarantäne frei testen die regelung gilt
auch für kitas wir waren uns im großen
und ganzen einig so viel
präsenzunterricht wie möglich zu
gewährleisten so viel infektionsschutz
wie nötig und das haben wir heute glaube
ich ganz gut geschafft indem wir gesagt
haben nur noch die ganz engen
kontaktpersonen die unmittelbar
tatsächlich bei der infizierten person
sind sollen wenn nötig in die quarantäne
gehen müssen ob die heute beschlossenen
regelungen dann tatsächlich überall
eingehalten werden wird man sehen die
schüler am gymnasium in meiningen waren
jedenfalls vor allem froh dass schule
für sie überhaupt wieder stattfindet
professor tobias tenenbaum ist
vorsitzender der deutschen gesellschaft
für pädiatrische infektiologie also
einfach mal wenn es um ansteckungsraten
bei kindern geht herr professor guten
abend entweder schon gelernt dann gucken
wir uns doch mal an was jetzt gelten
soll für schülerinnen und schüler in
deutschland nur noch enge
kontaktpersonen in quarantäne und von
der kann man sich dann nach fünf tagen
frei testen soll so eine art leitplanke
seien für die einzelnen gesundheitsämter
klingt jetzt vielleicht noch nicht
unbedingt nach einer einheitlichen
quarantäne regel und im moment ist es ja
bereits so dass es selbst von ort zu ort
teilweise komplett unterschiedlich
gehandhabt wird wie wichtig wären denn
aus ärztlicher sicht einheitliche regeln
ich finde es sehr gut dass einheitliche
regelungen gefunden worden sind wurde
höchste zeit dass dieser flickenteppich
an verschiedenen maßnahmen
bereinigt wurde und ich glaube dass das
eine sicherheit für die schüler und
schülerinnen in den schulen jetzt und
die auch die lehrer und eltern mit sich
bringt jetzt ist es ja so dass aktuell
also jetzt schon manche gesundheitsämter
unter
neun empfehlungen bleiben und sagen also
wenn masken getragen werden wenn viel
getestet wird dann gibt es gar keine
quarantäne mehr im klassenzimmer was ist
denn aus ärztlicher sicht aus ihrer
sicht die richtige methode dabei also es
ist durchaus so dass in einigen ländern
diese strategie gefahren wird dass wir
auch kinder im klassenverband halten
können und durch regelmäßiges testung
bei corolla kontakt den unterricht
weiter fortführen die sie aktuell
getroffene regelung ist aber auch schon
sehr viel besser als das was sie
vorhatten dass wir eben die kinder frei
testen können wenn sie eben eine
kontaktperson waren und dann eben nach
fünf tagen wie der früh in die schule
kommen können das ist schon ein
beachtlicher erfolg sie sagen ein
beachtlicher erfolg weil er natürlich
viel mehr kinder in der schule hält und
viel mehr kindern ermöglicht auch
durchgehend am unterricht
präsenzunterricht teilzunehmen auf der
anderen seite steht aber doch die gefahr
dass die kinder sich gegenseitig
anstecken oder halten sie diese gefahr
für sehr gering und für handelbar wir
sind in deutschland die situation dass
wir ohnehin keine no go it strategie wie
zb neuseeland fahren können auch dort
ist es bei niedriger incidents
letztendlich gescheitert und wir sollten
nicht versuchen jede infektion um jeden
preis zu verhindern denn wir müssen sie
ja die erkrankungszahlen die
infektionszahlen basieren mit dem
kindswohl dass sie auf anderer seite
eben auch garantieren müssen dass die
kinder nehme ich nicht zu hause bleiben
und von der schule oder von der kita
ferngehalten werden ok jetzt habe
geredet über die kinder die sich
anstecken die erkrankten an eine kurve
19 für die müssen natürlich auch noch
reden in den krankenhäusern da
beobachten sie auch die lage die daten
sehr genau wie sieht denn da die
situation bei kindern aus aktuell also
da ist die aktuelle fallzahl entwicklung
nicht so explosionsartig wie man das
vielleicht andernorts diskutiert wir
sehen eigentlich in den letzten
eineinhalb jahren eine doch relativ
geringe hospitalisationen rate also eine
krankenhauseinweisung rate von kindern
mit kuwait 19 auch wenn über eine halbe
million kinder in deutschland corinna
infektion hatten ist letztendlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ein kind deshalb
ins krankenhaus muss weiterhin doch sehr
gering auch trotz delta variante
und dann gibt es aber das phänomen longo
wird bei dem die datenlage bei kindern
noch sehr unklar ist wäre das etwas was
ihnen sorgen macht auch auf lange sicht
also da ist es so dass wir momentan noch
gar nicht sehr gut unterscheiden können
zwischen longkou bild und auch den
folgeerscheinungen die die kinder zeigen
nach den langen lockdown phasen sogar
lockdown phänomen das heißt wir sind in
den verschiedenen fachgesellschaften
momentan dabei kriterien zu arbeiten um
die diagnose überhaupt richtig zu
stellen die studienlage die momentan
dazu vorliegt ist auch noch sehr
unzureichend und wir können eben nicht
absehen wie groß dieses phänomen ist
wahrscheinlich ist eher eine
randerscheinung und ist eben nicht
vergleichbar mit den deutlichen
fallzahlen wie wir sie in der wachsen
medizin beobachten ich höre jetzt in dem
gespräch bei ihnen doch sehr viel heraus
was nach ich sag mal vorsichtige
entwarnung klingt wenn es um 19 und
kinder geht jetzt liest man auf der
anderen seite eine aktuelle inzidenz in
leverkusen bei den fünf bis 14 jährigen
von 855 wenn das jetzt erwachsene wären
und nicht kinder würden uns das ja sehr
sehr große sorgen machen bei kindern
bleiben sie aber gelassen ist das
richtig in der tat gelassener als bei
erwachsenen der ziel das wir uns vor
augen führen müssen ist ja dass wir
hospitalisationen also
krankenhauseinweisung schwere erkrankung
tod bei den
risiko-patienten also vor allen dingen
den älteren menschen erreichen wollen
das haben wir eigentlich in der pandemie
schon sehr gut erreicht noch nicht
vollständig aber da sind die kinder eben
kein wesentlicher bestandteil die dieses
phänomen drücken werden auch wenn wir
die kinder eben wegsperren und aus den
schulen weglassen das heißt da müssen
wir eben dafür plädieren dass nicht
jedes kind keine infektion bekommt
sondern wir müssen einen gewissen grad
an infektion eben zu lassen der ist
insgesamt muss man sagen sehr sehr
gering
zusammenfassend gesagt aus ihrer sicht
der professor wie sicher sind unsere
kinder jetzt auf dem weg in den herbst
in der schule
wir haben vielerorts sehr gute hygiene
konzepte erarbeitet wir haben die
impfung zur verfügung wir haben jetzt
eine gute quarantäne regelung gefunden
die auch weiterentwickelt werden kann
wir sind im städtischen des endet
fachgesellschaften und ich glaube wir
können die kinder sicher durch den
winter bringen und auch durch den herbst
und bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wir
keine explosionsartigen zahlen haben
werden professor tobias tenenbaum
herzlichen dank für das gespräch heute
abend vielen dank
und das gespräch aber kurz vor dieser
sendung aufgezeichnet nachher im
heute-journal update hat nason glückte
mir fragen an den vorsitzenden der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
und damit sind wir schon in der politik
zünglein an der waage königsmacher das
ist eine rolle in der sich jede partei
sehr wohl fühlen kann vor der wahl und
besser noch nach der wahl wenn es dann
tatsächlich so gekommen ist und sie
zünglein an der waage ist das ist bei
der fdp nicht anders auch wenn ihr chef
christian lindner natürlich nicht so
wirken darf als wäre er bereits beim
posten verteilen welche bündnisse die
zustimmung seiner fdp bekommen würden
und unter welchen bedingungen
dass es allerdings schon jetzt überaus
interessant zumal seine erklärten
lieblings konstellation in den umfragen
zunehmend unter die räder kommt bernd
weltin
es sind die wochen der farbenspiele fünf
koalitionskonstellationen sind gerade
denkbar drei davon gehen nur mit der
fdp-parteichef lindner aber betont
zuletzt für ein bündnis mit der spd
fehle ihm die fantasie in der sendung
was nun bekräftigt er seine inhaltlichen
bedenken ausschließen aber wohl eher
nichts ich habe großen respekt vor
unseren geschätzten mitbewerberinnen und
mitbewerber an spd und grüne sind
respektable parteien aber die haben ja
eigene inhalte wie wollen die steuern
erhöhen die schuldenbremse auf weichen
die grünen haben viele verbote im gepäck
das ist lindner war der vor vier jahren
die jamaika sondierungen platzen ließ
könnte in diesem jahr noch eine
entscheidende rolle spielen es ist
besser nicht zu regieren als falsch
zurück kehren das kalkül im holzlager
noch ein zweites mal können lindner die
regierungsverantwortung nicht ablehnen
auch nicht wenn es die spd wäre die zu
gesprächen einlädt scholz lässt die
option weiter köcheln und beschränkt
sich auf andeutungen christian lindner
sagt ihm fehle die fantasie für eine
koalition mit der spd nein sie dass nach
der wahl
stärker das mandat für mich und die spd
ausfällt umso besser wird es gelingen
eine gute regierung zu formt im zweifel
lässt die fdp mit sich reden glauben
auch die grünen und nutzen jede
gelegenheit lindner an die jamaika
flucht von 2017 zwei winter hat ja immer
das problem dass im zweifelsfall weg
läuft das muss ich selber klären ob er
dann weg ist ja oder nein dass herr
lindner natürlich jetzt alles daran
setzt dass seine voraussagen eintreten
die er mal gemacht hat dazu wäre
regierung übernimmt oder werde cantz das
kanzleramt übernimmt das sei
dahingestellt
vorausgesagt hatte lindner ein schwarz
gelbes bündnis mit armin laschet
inzwischen wirft er der cdu inhaltliche
schwammigkeit vor
es war lange unklar und ist es im grunde
bis heute für was steht die union in der
steuerpolitik im programm ist etwas
geschrieben worden von entlastungen das
hat herr laschet relativiert man weiß es
nicht mehr genau die linke präsentiert
heute ihr sogenanntes sofortprogramm
eine art bauplan für rot rot grün auch
sie schielt jetzt auf eine rolle in der
sich häufig schon die fdp wieder fand
die königsmacherin knapp drei wochen vor
der wahl kennzeichnen die ausgangslage
also vor allem zwei dinge sie ist sehr
dynamisch und sie ist sehr bunt
die lage in afghanistan wird uns noch
lange beschäftigen so auch heute abend
gundula hat mehr nach ihrem überraschend
schnellen eroberungszug in afghanistan
behaupten die taliban nun auch die
letzte bastion ihrer gegner unter ihre
kontrolle gezwungen zu haben das schwer
zu erobernde pandschir tal 100 kilometer
nördlich von kabul
bei schweren kämpfen dort soll es
mehrere todesopfer gegeben haben in der
provinz hatte ahmad massud widerstand
geleistet der sohn des von al qaida vor
20 jahren getöteten legendären
mudschaheddin kämpfers ahmad schah
massud von einem unbekannten ort aus
rief ahmad massud zu weiterem widerstand
gegen die taliban auf
knapp drei wochen vor der bundestagswahl
hat frankreichs präsident makro
spd-kanzlerkandidat scholz im
élyséepalast empfangen morgen wird
unionskandidat laschet in paris erwartet
grünen-kandidatin baerbock plant keinen
besuch bei makro eine gute stunde lang
sprachen scholz und makro über ein
starkes europa und die bedeutung der
deutsch-französischen zusammenarbeit im
bereich des klimaschutzes sowie in der
korona krise
eine bessere verteilung von corona
impfstoffen und eine bessere
vorbereitung auf kommende krisen diese
zielvorgaben haben die g20
gesundheitsminister in rom vereinbart in
einem sogenannten pakt von rom
verpflichten sich die g20 staaten dazu
den weltweiten zugang zu impfstoffen zu
sichern ziel sei bis ende des jahres
mindestens 40 prozent der
weltbevölkerung immunisiert zu haben die
bundesregierung hat eine
forschungsförderung zur entwicklung von
medikamenten gegen kuwait 19 beschlossen
sechs projekte deutscher firmen sollen
mit insgesamt 150 millionen euro
unterstützt werden das lka registrierte
vier
1749 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
190 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage instituts stieg auf
84,3 104 corona patienten wurden
innerhalb eines tages ins krankenhaus
eingewiesen die sieben tage inzidenz
hier ist aktuell gesunken auf
1,64 dieser wert lag im april bei knapp
einen tag nach dem umsturzversuch im
westafrikanischen guinea haben die
vereinten nationen die eu und die usa
den putsch verurteilt
eine gruppe militärs hatte gestern die
regierung abgesetzt und president condé
unter hausarrest gestellt der 83 jährige
hatte sich mit einer verfassungsänderung
eine dritte amtszeit ermöglicht seitdem
gab es immer wieder proteste ging er
zählt trotz vieler bodenschätze zu den
ärmsten ländern der welt
ich bin stolz auf sie das ist kein
urteil das ist vielmehr die rache der
behörden sagt der vater von maria callas
nico war heute an dem tag an dem seine
tochter zu elf jahren gefängnis
verurteilt wurde in einem geheimprozess
vor dem justizapparat des belarussischen
machthabers alexander lukaschenko der
weiß dass er sich nur noch dadurch an
der macht halten kann wenn er seine
politischen gegner gnadenlos weg
schließt und alles versucht um sie zum
schweigen zu bringen das verbrechen der
maria kalashnikova sie hatte sich
eingesetzt für demokratie menschenrechte
und freie wahlen christiansen berichtet
alexander und alexander zwei väter die
zur schicksalsgemeinschaft wurden was
sie verbindet ihre kinder sind
politische gefangene in belarus wally
für freiheit und gerechtigkeit kämpfen
stolz zeigen die väter die gesichter von
maria kohl s nikkor war und maxim's nach
mit den langjährigen haftstrafen hatten
auch sie gerechnet und sie haben angst
dass masche und maxim etwas passiert
natürlich fürchte ich dass weil sich
jeder vater oder jede mutter um die
gesundheit ihrer kinder sorgt ich kann
nicht sagen dass ich gut empfinde es ist
eher ein gefühl von machtlosigkeit dass
es unmöglich ist seiner tochter zu
helfen und all den anderen
der staat in dem wir leben so hat uns
dass der machthaber vermittelt hat keine
zeit für gesetze diese aussage ist sein
programm das sagt schon alles die
gesetze sind bei uns außer kraft gesetzt
heute im gericht ein herz trotz
handschellen maria kulissen die koffer
formt es kurz vor dem urteil neben ihrem
mitangeklagten maxim's nach mit dieser
geste ist sie bekannt geworden vor das
gerichtsgebäude in minsk kamen auch
einige unterstützer trotz der
systematischen repressionen und
brutalität gegen regierungsgegner in
belarus
ich habe prima wir halten das urteil für
widerrechtlich und unbegründet es
basiert nicht auf beweisen im verlauf
der gerichtlichen untersuchung des falls
sind weder ihre schuld noch die verübung
der verbrechen bestätigt worden der mann
sie bezichtigt
der vorwurf verschwörung zur
machtergreifung sowie der aufruf zu
aktionen gegen die nationale sicherheit
kohlessen die koffer waren letzten
jahren zu einer der prominenten
anführerinnen der massenproteste gegen
diktator lukaschenko geworden zusammen
mit präsidentschaftskandidatin svetlana
tier an oskar und veronika zepp carlo
kämpften drei frauen und hunderttausende
auf den straßen für ein freies belarus
lukaschenko ließ die proteste
niederknüppeln dazu misshandlungen in
den gefängnissen verhaftungen von
regierungsgegnern von journalistinnen
und journalisten und viel kritisierte
schauprozesse wir sind empört über
dieses urteil auch wenn es nicht
überraschend kam wir haben gesehen dass
dieser fall von anfang an völlig
erfunden war ganz offensichtlich aus
politischen gründen um maria kohlessen
die koffer maxim's nack und millionen
von menschen die ihnen folgten und an
friedlichen protesten teilgenommen haben
zum schweigen zu bringen
für die väter alexander und alexander
ist das urteil schwer zu ertragen
alexander kolesnikov sagt er fühle eine
schuld für seine generation
das was wir hätten machen müssen sagt er
machen jetzt unsere kinder
ganz anderes thema hierzu eine reine
auto show mit glänzenden karosserie
nimmermehr ps zierleisten und zylinder
das war die iaa mal das wird sie nie
wieder sein die welt der mobilität ist
in einem epochalen umbruch oder um es
ein bisschen hoffnungsvoller zu sagen
die zukunft ist so offen wie nie das
zeigt sich bei den ausstellern an den
ständen das zeigt sich auf münchens
straßen aus der internationalen
automobilausstellung wurde
mobility es gibt auch fahrräder zu sehen
und über diesel und benzin redet bei den
automanagern kaum noch wer alexander
pohl und peter meyer berichten
pedale stadt pferdestärken die einstige
leistungsschau der internationalen auto
branche verändert sich nicht nur
äußerlich die vielen fahrräder auf der
iaa sie stehen auch für eine neue idee
von mobilität die veränderungen die auf
die hiesigen hersteller zukommen sind
fundamental an absichtserklärungen
herrscht kein mangel die mobilität der
zukunft und was heißt dass das ist eine
dekarbonisierung mobilität also null
emissionen das elektroauto aber auch das
intelligente voll vernetzte fahrzeug
durch digitalisiert und kann mit allen
anderen verkehrsträgern sprechen
sozusagen als die hauptaussage hier in
münchen ist die zukunft der mobilität
und die ist durch zwei große themen
geprägt nachhaltigkeit spricht co2
reduzierung und das andere ist wie der
verwendung von rohstoffen das klingt
erst mal gut doch die zweifel über die
ernsthaftigkeit solcher vorhaben sind
nicht ausgeräumt das erreichen der
klimaziele für viele ein
lippenbekenntnis
umweltverbände gehen derzeit juristisch
gegen führende deutsche autobauer vor
und selbst in den büros weltweit tätiger
unternehmensberatungen weiß man die zeit
drängt reicht der anspruch den die
unternehmen mittlerweile formuliert
haben um die dekarbonisierung der
wertschöpfungskette voranzutreiben da
würde ich sagen da hat sich extrem viel
getan reicht es in dem heutigen stand
der umsetzung da würde ich sagen da
stehen wir gerade noch am anfang das
heißt die themen müssen jetzt angegangen
werden sie müssen umgesetzt werden und
doch gibt es unter mobilitäts experten
die vielleicht überraschende erkenntnis
dass wir auch künftig am auto nicht
vorbeikommen das auto wird bleiben es
wird sich verändern es wird in ganz
unterschiedlichen erscheinungsformen
auftreten und ich glaube dass es auch
wichtig ist dass wir selbst
selbstständig in unserer eigenen
mobilitäts entscheidungen bleiben dass
ein stück der kultur
und es ist alles andere als eine
entwarnung der druck auf die deutschen
autobauer wächst von zwei seiten
chinesische hersteller drängen mit macht
auf den europäischen markt für
elektroautos und der mangel an
mikrochips zentrale bauteile des
digitalisierten fahrens lässt die
produktion vieler ort stillstehen was
genau dabei rauskommt dass das weiß ich
nicht genau wie ich die lottozahlen der
nächsten woche nicht weiß aber wir gehen
im moment davon aus dass es etwa eine
fünfstellige zahl von autos sein wird
die wir dieses jahr nicht bauen können
und die am jahresende fehlen werden die
iaa in münchen versucht wege in die
zukunft der mobilität zu zeigen die
lange erfolgreiche deutsche
autoindustrie beschreitet diesen weg am
ziel ist sie noch lange nicht
ja wenn man sich anguckt wie mau ist
immer noch aussieht etwa mit
ladestationen in diesem land dann ist
der weg doch noch ein sehr weiter oder
jemand wirft mal einen echten turbo an
hier jetzt in der sendung noch mal gut
lachen die umstrittenen gas pipeline
nord stream 2 ist mit dem heutigen tag
fast fertiggestellt das letzte rohr
seifer schweiz teilte die betreiberfirma
mit und werde jetzt auf den meeresboden
abgesenkt damit werden in dem
politischen streit über eine mögliche
abhängigkeit von russland weitere fakten
geschaffen frank bethmann die pipeline
ist aber auch wirtschaftlich umstritten
ja sehr sogar energieexperten sagen
schlicht und ergreifend nord stream 2
wird nicht rentabel zu betreiben sein
eigentlich sei die röhre gar nicht nötig
denn es gebe bereits ausreichend wege
gas nach europa zu befördern
andererseits ist deutschland innerhalb
der eu eben auch der größte abnehmer von
russischem erdgas und eine
direktverbindung könne russisches gas
billiger machen sagen die befürworter
was allerdings umstritten ist hinter
nord stream 2 steht gazprom der
russische staatskonzern trägt auch die
hälfte der geplanten gesamtkosten von
9,5 milliarden euro die andere hälfte
finanzieren weitere große
energiekonzerne darunter die deutschen
firma wintershall der und juniper die
neue pipeline die noch in die jahr in
betrieb genommen werden soll habe nach
eigentümer angaben eine jährliche
kapazität von 55 milliarden kubikmetern
gas genug um 26 millionen haushalte
damit zu versorgen doch wer braucht
diese mengen eigentlich noch für die eu
mit ihren strengen klimapolitischen
zielen ist erdgas ein energieträger mit
ablaufdatum umweltaktivisten nennen die
ostseepipeline
investitionsruine und selbst die die es
mit nord stream zwei besser meint
schätzen dass deutschland nur noch
wenige jahre vom russischen erdgas
abhängig sein wird zunehmend so die
prognosen dürfte gas durch erneuerbare
energien ersetzt werden
frank bethmann für die einordnung
deutschlands botschafter in china yang
hacker ist im alter von 54 jahren nach
nur wenigen tagen im amt überraschend
gestorben die außenministerien in berlin
sowie in peking äußerten sich bestürzt
die todesursache sei unklar es gebe
keinen zusammenhang mit hackers position
als botschafter vor dieser aufgabe war
der jurist jahrelang außenpolitischer
berater von kanzlerin merkel die hackers
herausragende fachkenntnis würdigte
eine meldung vom tennis im achtelfinale
der us open in new york ist angelique
kerber ausgeschieden sie verlor gegen
die kanadierinnen leila fernandes
dagegen geht die erfolgsserie von
alexander zverev weiter der
weltranglisten vierte gewann gerade eben
gegen den italiener jannik sinne und der
kölner oscar otte kämpft zur stunde um
den einzug ins viertelfinale ebenfalls
gegen einen italiener matteo barry
teenie
kunden der deutschen bahn können ab
morgen wieder mit einem weitgehend
normalen zugverkehr rechnen nachdem
bislang dritten streik in der laufenden
tarifrunde droht der vorsitzende der
lokführergewerkschaft weselsky
allerdings mit weiteren
arbeitsniederlegungen wie in den
vergangenen fünf tagen 70 der fernzüge
fielen aus einer einigung im tarifstreit
ist bislang nicht in sicht im zdf lehnte
weselsky weitere verhandlungen mit der
bahn ab sollte diese kein
verhandlungsfähiges angebot vorlegen
ach dieses zerknautschte boxer gesicht
dein aussehen macht eine kinokarriere
wenig wahrscheinlich sagten sie ihm ich
dachte nie daran eines tages berühmt zu
werden mit meinem gesicht hatte ich
nichts von einem verführer an mir sagte
er selbst und dann 80 filme später ein
herzensbrecher draufgänger und action
held eine kultfigur des französischen
kinos
jean paul belmondo und sein breites
grinsen unverschämt lässig unerschrocken
cool das wird bleiben auch nach dem tod
des schauspielers heute unsterblich
werden und dann sterben das zitat stammt
aus belmondos legendären film außer atem
und so kam es jean paul belmondo wollte
profi boxer werden aber in dieser rolle
hatte er wenig erfolg stattdessen machte
belmondo eine schauspielausbildung bekam
auftritte an pariser bühnen und dann im
film mit romy schneider in ein engel auf
erden
sie sind ein sehr netter junge
dank der durchbruch kam 1960 außer atem
machte belmondo zum star der film wird
ein klassiker des internationalen kinos
wenn mondo spielte mit ursula andress
jeanne moreau und sophia loren hier im
film und dennoch leben sie ein merkmal
belmondos er machte seine stunts selber
am ende blickte er auf 80 filme zurück
es ist etwas besonderes am ersten tag
weiß fantastisch und ich 40 jahre später
ist es das immer noch
1999 erleidet belmondo einen
schwächeanfall auf der bühne zwei jahre
später einen schlaganfall er ist danach
halbseitig gelähmt und kämpft sich
mühsam ins leben zurück kollegen und
freunde reagieren am abend auf die
nachricht vom tod belmondos alan joyce
sagte im französischen radio es ist
furchtbar ich bin am boden zerstört
frankreich würdigt einen künstler der
den ruf des landes in der welt mit
geprägt hat wie sehr belmondo im land
verankert war erkennt man auch daran wer
sich von ihm verabschiedet die polizei
würde ich ihn als großen kino bull in
die fremdenlegion sagt adieu belmondo
und präsident makro lobte in den
höchsten tönen jean paul belmondo war
ein nationaler schatz ein erhabener hält
und eine vertraute gestalt ein
unermüdlicher draufgänger und zauberer
der worte in ihm fanden wir uns alle
wieder
belmondo war mehrmals verheiratet hatte
vier kinder und sechs enkelkinder der
mann in dem sich die französische nation
wieder fand wurde 88 jahre alt
ein nachruf von thomas walde war das und
das heute journal an diesem montag geht
damit zu ende von uns allen hier danke
dass sie dabei war gegen 23.45 meldet
sich nah sein dürfte mehr mit unserem
heutigen update in einen angenehmen
abend bis morgen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ja das
spätsommerliche warme wetter setzt sich
fort geht in die verlängerung und zwar
mit diesem umfangreichen hochs hat sich
auch nach osteuropa hin ausgedehnt aber
wir haben sie auch mit einem tief zu tun
in den nächsten tagen das bringt in der
zweiten wochenhälfte dann schauer und
gewitter mit der blick auf die kommende
nacht zeigt uns im norden gibt es
deutlich mehr wolken als im südwesten
örtlich bildet sich nebel
und die temperaturen sinken an den alpen
auf 8 grad und 14 bis 15 grad nach
südwesten hin morgen löst sich der nebel
zunächst einmal auf und dann kommt die
sonne hervor aber weiterhin ist er im
norden mehr bewölkung anzutreffen als
zum beispiel im südwesten scheint häufig
die sonne nach südosten hin bilden sich
schauer und gewitter und das bevorzugt
in den nachmittagsstunden temperaturen
im süden ziemlich warm bis zu 29 grad
richtung oberer allen 27 grad im rhein
main gebiet aber sie sehen schon im
westen und im süden ist es deutlich
wärmer als nach nordosten in am kühlsten
an der ostsee mit 20 grad die kommenden
tage es bleibt zunächst einmal war
mittwoch bis 28 grad und häufig
sonnenschein vor allem nach
nebelauflösung donnerstag dann erste
schauer und gewitter mit dem tief dass
sich dann annähert und dann werte bis 28
grad und am freitag können die schauer
und gewitter sogar auch heftiger
ausfallen sogar mit platzregen und hagel
und damit wünsche ich ihnen ein schöner
abend